ciao a benvenuti al alessio name you
will say the speak Italian with your
mouth full benvenuti is welcome to the
lecture number six before you watch this
video i recommend to check the link
above because there is some useful
vocabulary and some sentences that will
help you to understand what's going on
one divertimento have fun Molina estas
lavando y como dorina Mario Sara n das
Stan no te ando lay melon sanaz Stan no
te ando milan-san meant it suck stop
falando eat funny duck stop
and cha-cha-cha Anita metas blechy poll
Nellis pentola or stop me tengo la chupo
la talla gotta cut nila pentola
finishing water a decimal to avoid
metallic implant ah a listen baby's lung
David for charity Yong Yong love it bye
bye k dot it yeah love it love at it see
my God look at em waka ama school from
the beaches no no no Zach stop metendo
II pomodori knee sewell pan ah miss Cole
at 0 e pomodori me so he mixed ma
Schelotto llamo dharini con óleo salad I
Basilico a adesso star metendo e como
Doreen e chi fan le bruschetta so no
raanta bon apetito my channel antipasto
also on that again by sea but ok